we met for the first time since the
entry into force of our association
agreements and a visa-free travel for
Ukrainians to the European Union and
there's two achievements show that by
working closely together we can achieve
really tangible and positive results for
our citizens today we discussed recent
progress in the many significant reforms
Ukraine is undertaking I would like to
highlight for example reforms in the
social sphere like the healthcare and
Pensions reform and energy the fight
against corruption is the foundation for
all reforms much has been achieved but
there are some policy conditions in the
fight against corruption that still have
to be met and I know our personally
dedicated the Prime Minister is to this
fight the devotion and perseverance of
the civil society in Ukraine is truly
exceptional and really a strong asset to
the country the European Union remains
unwavering in its support for Ukraine's
territorial integrity and sovereignty we
follow very closely the developments on
the ground in eastern Ukraine today we
also witness the signature of a
financing agreement for the EU support
program to eastern Ukraine this is 50
million euro contribution we also took
the opportunity to reiterate the non
recognition policy of the illegal
annexation of Crimea and Sevastopol
we also condemned the ongoing
militarization of the Crimean Peninsula
and the deterioration of the human
rights situation during we also repeat
our call for the immediate release of
all Ukrainian citizens detained
illegally in illegally annexed Crimea
and in Russia does the Sylvania ximena's
tomorrow see here
yes Kosta reached him some of whom would
see the progeny with visa version policy
upon the SEMA really zone I just put
chapter GU stupa love GU would process
with the Europeans a user for attention
on me but she would knee should not
shaken emissions parents never operative
he will nearly double its effectiveness
mine would watch TV with caused a Stein
your initial aim minestrone are given a
media Kumu your questa users at the dot
Corbett are given a preference